Speaker 1: All right, let's speak to a few
more people via discord.
You can join at David Pakman dot com slash
discord.
Let's go next to Eva from Boston, Eva from
Boston.
Your next up, what's going on today?
What's on your mind?
Speaker 5: Hi, David.
Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 5: OK, great.
So, you know, I'm having a good day.
My first time getting on the call you.
So I'm happy I'm getting the chance to question
about Afghanistan.
So since Saudi Arabia recently started things
that we're doing more progressive, not where
we would want them to be, obviously, but,
you know, they're allowing women to drive.
Do you think that if we never went into Afghanistan
or if we left maybe 10 years ago, that they
would naturally progress towards progressiveness
as we see a lot of these more conservative
countries tend to do over the years?
And additionally, what major legislation would
you do with that money if we never went into
Afghanistan or we left after maybe 10 years?
Speaker 1: Well, the second part is, is, you
know, there's no specific legislation.
It's all the things we've been talking about
already that they love to say, well, how are
we going to pay for that?
They'd be saying anyway.
But, you know, we're talking about expanding
health care, improving education, advancing
alternative and renewable energy.
The list would be the same.
It's just we would have one more, one more
sort of sort of like a tranche of money available.
But they would still say we don't have the
money to pay for it in terms of whether Afghanistan
would have sort of naturally on its own liberalized
had we never gone in or left 10 years ago.
It's an impossible question.
I think it's completely impossible to say
there are some countries where that has been
the direction and others where it hasn't.
But I think what's important to know about
Saudi Arabia and I recently read a good book
about it, about the rise of Mohammed bin Salman,
is that there is a big component of it that's
basically marketing and optics where it's
in order to be able to get Saudi Arabia wants
to diversify away from oil and they want to
take the oil money and invest elsewhere, like
in Hollywood films and in dotcom startups,
tech startups, et cetera.
And in order to be better seen in that world,
they've done some of the liberalization.
And so I'm not saying it's not in good faith
or that it is, but I think there's a big aspect
of this that's to their advantage for their
financial goals.
And so I have no idea in Afghanistan, it's
a very different situation, but I don't think
we would be any worse off had we left 10,
12, 14, 16, 18 years ago.
Speaker 5: Mm hmm.
Yeah.
I mean, I'd have preferred to see us leave,
uh, maybe never have gone in, but I don't
know.
I was too young to really understand what
was going on in that time.
But thank you for taking my call.
I love seeing people of Latin culture represent
themselves, especially after the changing
census.
I'm really excited to hear about that either.
And last question, what's your favorite, lesser
known Mexican dish?
Because mine is money and minable.
Speaker 1: I don't know that I you know, I
am not fully a connoisseur of Mexican food,
so I don't know that I have anything unique
to really put forward there, but I like all
of it.
Speaker 5: Thanks so much.
Speaker 1: All right.
Thanks, Eva.
Eva
from Boston.
Great
to hear from her.